hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game from round one of the
american cup that started today a lot of
you have already suggested it and as
usual for good reasons uh it is a game
of many ups and downs but ultimately it
is the final position that will bring a
well i i i dare say a huge smile on
everyone's face
uh so let's dive straight into it it's
wesley so versus samuel savion wesley
has the white pieces and he opens with
d4 ah sorry about that
uh we have knight to f6 uh by savion uh
c4 with e6 knight to c3 and bishop to b4
seems like everyone is playing the names
of indian nowadays uh and we uh
discussed that usually uh a3 and queen
to c2 are considered the absolute top
most sound moves a3 is something that
we've covered a lot lately as
people have used it to maybe avoid the
queen c2 or e3 line uh we've even shown
knight to f3 i think yesterday and here
we have the standard e3 the so-called
traditional line we have castles by
savion and bishop to d3 by wesley the
so-called bishop attack against the
nimzo indian we're going to put our
queen on c2 and we're going to have a
nice queen bishop battery along this
diagonal so d5 black strikes in the
center as one usually does when going
for the nimso indian and now c captures
on d5 usually uh just continuing
development is the way to go here i
guess wesley wants to take
samuel out of the book very early on so
e captures on d5 and now a3 we challenge
the bishop but there's no need to trade
our bishop for a knight now we just go
back bishop to d6 and queen to c2 now
yeah we have c6 strengthening our d5
pawn and knight g to e2 by wesley we
have rooked the e8 and now the shot to
d2
knight b to d7 both players just
continuing development putting pieces on
optimal squares and now f3 so it seems
that wesley will castle queenside and he
is setting up for a nice kingside attack
as black already castled and uh well you
you know where to attack so c5 uh we
often say that the absolute best way to
counter attack
your opponent's attack on the king side
is to counter attack in the center of
the board uh wesley strikes with h4 and
here there are two games that have
reached this position uh where a6 was
played but here savion plays h5 and it
is now as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game uh so let's see uh
how does wesley go about to this uh he
castles queen side first uh we have a6
and now uh there's no more uh uh time to
to waste uh he strikes uh on the king
side with the g4 now this means that he
is giving up a pawn uh but what is one
pawn uh when you can open up a nice g
file for your rook and you can start the
attack a little bit earlier so h
captures on g4 f captures knight
captures on g4 and now
we have h5 you could also consider
knight captures on d5 it's a fun line
that we can show for example c captures
on d4 e captures on d4 and now you have
to play knight to d to f6 uh going for
material with knight to f2 isn't really
all that great because rook h to g1 and
black is already in a lot of trouble for
example you grab the rook queen captures
on d1 and white has a very nice
attacking resources here the pawn is
marching forward the queen is coming to
f1 you can
it's very easy to organize an attack
here so basically what you would do is
just put the knight on f6 and uh
it's it's a it's a position that you can
play however wesley goes for the full
attack he goes for h5 and now we have
knight back to f8 again uh you could go
for knight to f2 here but uh
for example if knight to f2 here wesley
could just strike with h6 right away and
now let's say knight captures an h1
there's even this beautiful bishop to h7
check king h8h captures on g7 king g7
and now rook the g1 with check came to
f8 and now rook to g8 with check king e7
knight captures on d5 king e6 and queen
to f5 checkmate so it's not a completely
forced line but you will uh get in a lot
of trouble if you try go for going for
material here so knight back to the f8
we need to help out with the defense
here especially with the h7 square uh
and now comes rook d the g1 here uh
maybe uh continuing with h6 would have
been a little bit better but it's always
uh
difficult to choose when to push that
pawn for example here h6 is just very
very strong uh savion would of course
counter with g6 and then the position
continues of course you can never
capture with the knight because really d
to g1 and uh you will not be able to
defend this there's already the threat
of just rogue captures on h6 and it's a
terrible position for black but instead
we have rook d to g1 that makes sense
you want to have both of yours ready to
attack here but now knight to f2 is a
viable option and this is exactly what
samuel goes for
the captures on c5 by wesley again h6 is
probably a little bit better but okay d
captures on c5 and now not the bishop
captures in c5 but rather bishop to e5
there's no reason to grab this pawn you
would only run into trouble and the
reason wesley did this is so he can win
the f4 square for his knight and get
another attacker into the game so of
course we're not going to allow this
savion goes for bishop to e5 and the
bishop is an excellently placed piece
here not only is it a great attacker but
it's also a great defender of black's
position here so finally wesley does
push h6 now we have g6 and h7 with check
and you get this position what do you
play here can you grab the pawn or do
you ignore the pawn and hide the king
well it's a very very uh short line so
we can just show it if you capture here
then bishop captures on g6 and black's
position just falls apart for example
knight g5 we want to keep the g file
closed uh we're going to play knight to
f4 we just add more firepower here and
after something like king to f8 we can
even play bishop captures on f7 so this
is uh you can pretty much play whatever
you want here and you're gonna win this
position with white uh let's say knight
captures knights the g6 check we force
the king back to the g file king g7 now
we can pick up this with checking back
to a fade knight g6 jack king goes back
we go knight to f for a discovery again
from the rook and after king f8 there's
even the beautiful rook the g8 check and
uh okay now you can go to e7 but still
it's not going to be enough we just
start gobbling up on the d d5 pawn or if
capture is just queen to h7 checking
here and now knight to g6 will be
checkmate just to show you uh what uh
what a crazy attacking position this is
and if savion doesn't want to lose this
terribly he has to play everything
perfectly so king the h8 the only good
move for black and now we have rook to
h6 by wesley it's not all that easy
continuing this attack uh as uh sevien
is defending extremely well but now rook
h6 now we put even more pressure on that
g6 spawn and here comes bishop to g7 he
says all right uh get your rook away
from there wesley has to go back rook h2
and now knight the g4 we uh get our
knight back into the game with tempo the
rook is attacked rook to h3 now knight
to e5 and now we can capture the bishop
on d3 at will uh thus removing one of
the attackers so here rook h the g3
again wesley piles up on that g pawn and
now while you could capture the bishop
right away there's really no need to do
it uh knight the e6 is played so uh
wesley uh wesley is now uh
uh being tasked with uh
finding a continuation to this attack
and it's not easy uh he finds knight to
f4 but that's exactly why the knight was
placed here uh so you cannot get this
knight into the game uh but there is no
better move uh of course you can always
play something like b4 but that's that
would be a very very slow it would be
like claiming yeah okay my position is
totally fine let's just push a pawn on
the queen side uh so knights the f4 here
and finally we have a trade knight
capture spawn captures and now
only now when you have to move the
knight will you trade on d3 with check
we have queen captures on d3 and now d4
and grabbing more space here forcing the
knight to move uh knights the e4 and now
a beautiful queen to d5 uh this isn't uh
only uh
centralizing the queen but it also comes
with tempo the knight is now hanging and
uh you can't really defend it if you
play rook to e1 bishop to f5 and that's
it
wesley can resign so instead wesley
plays knight to g5 now he's ready to put
even more pressure on the black king but
now queen captures on c5 with check we
have king to d1 if king to b1 again
bishop f5 is game over so we have to put
the king to d1 and now queen back to d5
now you can see that 7 has some ideas of
maybe even infiltrating on the queen
side here
and the problem for wesley is that it's
not all that easy to
figure out how to continue the attack
the f7 square is covered by the queen
and how are you pushing through here so
wesley says all right maybe it's time to
cut our losses uh we are not breaking
through here queen to f3 is played
but now comes uh queen to a2 and this in
fact is not the absolute best way to
play this it's a very very tricky
position best way to play this is just
bishop to e6 but uh you know tell the
truth uh who who who amongst us would
play bishop to e6 here so queen to 82
was played but now wesley finds a
beautiful uh equalizing idea knight
captures on f7 with check queen captures
on f7 and the rook captures on g6 and
now you're threatening to just pick up
the bishop and then pick up the queen
and you will have sufficient
compensation as you have the bishop the
queen and the past f-pawn which should
be easily winning for you uh the problem
is there is one move that saves a savion
and it's a very very difficult move to
spot so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the only move that
it doesn't lose for samuel
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is pawn to d3
that's the good stuff sometimes in such
a such a terribly tricky uh position you
have to spot a move like this what it
does is that it cuts off the whites
white queens control over the b3 square
and now queen to b3 is definitely a
threat the problem is if you guys were
considering samus like let's just move
the bishop then there's rook g8 to check
and after king captures an h7 queen h1
and that's it there's no uh recovering
from this or if you tried something else
for example rook the e7 you want to
trade here or maybe defend the white
would very very happily trade here
you're gonna start pushing your f1 you
have a queen and the bishop and this
will be winning for white so the only
way not to lose this with black is to
play d3 once again congratulations to
everyone who spotted this uh and the the
idea is that uh if queen captures on d3
then we have bishop to f5 this freeing
move and then black is back in the game
the problem is uh this is the only way
for wesley to continue playing this game
and we will show it because it's
extremely important so queen captures on
d3 is a must
and the bishop to f5 comes next
attacking the rook and the queen we're
going to play rook captures on g7 here
uh but of course now comes queen to h5
check king to c1 uh we pick up the white
queen and now rook the c7 a very
important move as it prevents the rook
from delivering check to the white king
and now how are you stopping bishop to
c3 check wow what uh what a position uh
there is only one move uh that uh
prevents wesley from winning this and
that is a rook to e7 we uh cut off this
rook's defense of the h pawn and now
bishop to c3 check can be made met with
king captures and h7 and after rook
captures an e7 check we unfortunately
had to give up the rook for this king h6
now bishop to g7 check and we are now
entering a threefold repetition uh
because
neither side can make any progress here
king h7 we're going to play king bishop
to e5 check open up a discovery here you
can see all of the squares are are
covered
except for the h6 square and there's no
way to increase the pressure here so
here we would have to
settle for a nice perpetual and it would
end in a draw
wesley did not go for this after d3
wesley played bishop to e3 giving his
king the d2 square to hide uh heidi's
king the problem is uh this does not
work as uh savion quickly shows he plays
queen to b3 with check king to e1 of
course king c1 queen to c2 checkmate so
king e1 now comes d2 with check uh that
king is never reaching that d2 square
and also if you played king to d2 then
we have just queen to c to check king e1
d2 everything comes with check and now
the queen is even better positioned here
so there really isn't all that much you
can do here so king the e1 is a little
bit better but d2 comes with check and
now you simply can't capture with the
bishop uh due to the rule being here if
you capture with the king then again you
uh
pretty much any move black plays is
winning but the simple bishop f5
bringing the rook into the game will be
sufficient let's say rook captures on g7
queen to d3 checking a1 rook captures on
e3 we pick up the queen we check made
the white king
and that's it uh so after d2 check king
the f2 was played and now comes the uh a
final move of the game and that is pawn
to d1 and uh here savion promotes it to
a queen and he was in this position on
move 36 that wastely so resigned in the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here but what i find uh spectacular
about this position is that it doesn't
matter what you uh bring
into the game for example uh if you
bring uh a bishop into the game uh
there's still no move for white you
don't really have to bring a queen into
the game your white's queen is now under
attack and there's no good move here you
can play queen captures on d1 but now
you no longer have control over the e3
square and after king g2 you're gonna
play queen e4 check king h2 queen f4
check because the king cannot remain on
the g file you're gonna pick up the rook
uh once you block this we're gonna play
queen f to check you're gonna block this
queen h4 check and that's pretty much it
king g1 bishop d4 check and now
okay what do you play here queen
characters on d4 we're gonna pick up the
queen and very quickly checkmate the uh
the the white king it seems like white
has something here but not really uh the
h pawn is undefended so that's that's a
big issue so another thing after king
king to f2 you could also play d1 knight
you could bring a knight into the game
with tempo now okay let's say you
capture with the rook still doesn't
matter queen to c2 with check and after
the queen blocks now we just pick up the
rook here queen captures on g6 white has
nothing here black is up a full bishop
and a full rook uh and uh lastly of
course after king to f2 you could also
bring a rook into the game
but still there is nothing for for white
to try here we've already tried
everything if you if you capture the
bishop here let's say rook captures on
g7 we can just capture the pawn on b2
and after some like king to g3 or
if you go anywhere along the g file then
the g7 rook is no longer protected so
you're going to have to block with
something like queen to e2 not just
queen captures an e2 king captures an e2
and the rook captures on g1 white is
simply down too much material rook
captures king captures and now you are
up a full rook of course completely
winning here so it's uh really an
amazing position where
especially uh you know between top grand
masters where you can promote upon uh on
move 36 and it doesn't matter what you
promote it to everything is completely
winning so i thought you guys
might enjoy this one uh so yeah that's
the game big congratulations to savion
on such a such a spectacular game wesley
could have um
could have won if things went a little
bit more his way but it was like i said
a game of many ups and downs uh but when
savion spotted this uh brilliant
brilliant d3 move that well it's
basically the only move that saves the
position cuts of the b3 square from the
white queen uh this uh bishop to e3
simply was insufficient queen captures
on d3 was a must wesley didn't play it
and thus he lost the game uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
the first round of the american cup has
uh finished uh
uh i would like to thank uh dave ellis
usfd efra usfdfri and nicolas padal for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it uh as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions such as
this one
and whatever else is happening in the
chess world so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day